kansas city i can't wait to get to your
wonderful town i'll be there january
20th through the 22nd get your tickets
for those dates and all dates at
ryansickler.com
hey i know them shoes
i know them night pants hell yeah y'all
know who this is
it's your boy
ryan
chipping it with the pinky in the air
cause they just don't care
[Music]
don't look at me you better walk away
man it's the honeydew with your boy ryan
sickler you all better subscribe today
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all of your
social media night pants nation tour is
still underway here we're now into
january i'll be at in kansas city
january 20th through the 22nd i'll be in
vancouver
i just said vancouver i'm reading
vancouver february
17th to the 19th tickets available at
ryansickler.com
please subscribe to the youtube channel
uh i love that the community continues
to grow and grow you guys are supportive
is i
what i i start every show by thanking
everybody and i i say legit i've i've
for the better part of two years i've
sat in a 10 by 10 room doing this show
listening to people telling me the worst
[ __ ] about their lives
and along with all i've laughed right in
their [ __ ] faces and i can't thank
you enough for allowing me to heal the
way we need to heal y'all uh patreon
honeydew with y'all
one of my favorite [ __ ] things to do
uh it's the honeydew
and it's with y'all it's five bucks a
month sign up for a year you get over a
month free um you also get the honeydew
a day early ad free at no additional
cost i'm keeping it at five bucks all
right i know that's a lot of money for
some people so um you know like i said
if you know you're in for the year sign
up you save all right
that's the deal you know we do here we
highlight the low lights these are the
stories behind the storytellers and uh
it's my pleasure to kick off
uh the early part of 2022 with one of
the most requested guests ladies and
gentlemen welcome back jason ellis
welcome back to the honeydew jj alice
thanks for having me man thank you for
being here dude please promote away you
know the deal oh uh the jason ellis show
it's on uh you know everywhere where the
podcasts are and it's on youtube and all
that baloney sandwich and i have a
patreon as well patreon.com forward
slash alice mate where i do two jason
ella shows a week and two
solo shows just myself and my wife
uh called awesome world
and then i have a podcast with the great
tony hawk and that is called hawk vs
wolf which is available
everywhere
and that's pretty much it clothing
company wolf knives with knives
store.com i [ __ ] love your hoodie
dude it's a good thick warm hoodie yeah
it was a little bit you know how people
want to do the cheapest one because
that's usually how you make the most
money
and i was like but i i wear them i i
started my clothing company because i
wanted to wear my own [ __ ] and if you
don't buy it i don't care it's coming
back to me right now isn't is this the
clothing company you started with the
pay out from your ex of
[Laughter]
thanks for reminding me of that because
that does make me feel better about that
it's still going
got new stuff in the store right now i'm
actually going to bring out skateboards
now because
i used to have them in a pack when you
because you can sign up you got to give
us a skateboard to put in the studio
yeah all right yeah we're showing up in
the office for sure are you going to put
you mean a deck you're going to have
yeah i'm going to give myself a pro
model again because i skate all the time
now and there's this other company bad
grease and they they make a jason ellis
model but now that i skate
i'm like wait you know like i i want to
i just want my own board and i don't
want to ask because right now i get
boards from like tony hawk or bucky
lassic and i used to be pro it's weird
to get boards from them i want to get my
home yeah i mean bucky's a baltimore guy
so we all think he's you know we're high
on bucky well he's the [ __ ] he's still
man he's so funny you said tony hawk
said he's the best vert skater i believe
right now yeah yeah i mean there's a
couple of other new guys that are there
i skated with bucky the other day and
he's like man i'm sore i'm you know it's
getting tough well this is what i was
just talking about how much longer
that's going for how old's he now
49 i think and you're what 50. okay and
what's tony
53 or 54. okay do you think
there are more 40-plus 50-ish men
skateboarding now than ever have in the
history of the planet earth yeah what do
you think we just know about it more
because of technology no because tony
and i have discussed this and it's
uh he did a legends demo in in utah and
i was the announcer and i just started
skating again and there was a contest
with all the best dudes in the world
there was a street contest uh like in
the same area that's on tv like a
televised one so all the best dudes on
street and then there was a thing called
the legends demo where it was just the
older guys they did a demo not a contest
some of them like myself had not been
skating all the time and verse skating
is a thing where if you drop off
it's [ __ ] sketchy
it's
it's dangerous yeah so they did
nowhere near as good as they could do
and and the place erupted
so hard and the streets the streets the
street guys came over to the vert demo
and started filming it because they were
like this is the coolest [ __ ] ever and i
felt like some of them had never seen a
vert demo up close and they're like whoa
i just always think this [ __ ] was
because bird dudes are cheese street
took over and because vert was so big at
one point we were just the uncool
like grandpa man it's like i had bus
socks on wherever i bus socks on or
something like nobody accepted you
anymore
uh i went to the x games in minneapolis
a few years ago and
watching these guys i mean fly
yeah fly and i'm down right there we had
a buddy of mine gave us all access and
he took me up in the elevator and that
was a time at the no pun intended the
height of my being scared of heights and
i'm up there and i'm peeking over on the
ramp and i'm i'm scared to look over and
i'm like you're gonna drop in off this
you're gonna hit that [ __ ] and
you're gonna fly you're not just gonna
fly
you're gonna do some kind of [ __ ]
spin some trick or whatever and then
boom and only a couple of them are
landing but but also what blew me away
was that
even though they were crashing or
whatever you call it missing bailing
bailing they were bailing gracefully it
wasn't ugly every one of them hitting
the knees and sliding and popping right
up and going up again if you don't know
how to do that you're dead and i just
thought
to figure out a way to uh [ __ ] up you
know what i mean without hurting
yourself is so that's why i really think
skaters just get it
yeah i know it more now than ever
because i've been out for 15 years and
now that i'm back you know people seem
it seems faster it seems more dangerous
and i'm i'm like wow i used to do this
like uh no big deal
these guys the new guys that are out
here killing it i'm like man you guys
are [ __ ] psychotic do you realize
that yeah and they're like dude you're
up here and i'm like
oh yeah cool but if you put enough work
in then it becomes
a you know it should be you're a lot
safer but right now i'm still in the
pocket i got hurt more in the last six
months of trying to get skateboarding
back then
like i got knocked out i think three
concussions
you know i've i've like
ripped skin off yeah i'm worried but we
were standing outside and you remember
the the
yeah that we did that episode well you
remember we did it you didn't think it
was released yep
yeah even though i even though i liked
it did you tag me yeah did i like it
yeah
yeah you did you did all those things
you gotta look he could it's a it could
it would be sadder if i was uh very in
like a really intelligent uh history
teacher but i'm jason if i don't
remember stuff it's it's smooth for me
all right i know you brought stories to
tell us but i want to ask you written
down because i can't remember that well
this is what i wanted to ask you are you
are you worried about that dementia any
of the cte
have you gone to get a study done on
your brain they can't do that you have
to be dead for that no i don't mean that
i mean brain waves and wavelengths and
things like that where they can actually
map and tell you like where damage is
can they do that yeah i think i'm all
right
like i was always pretty punchy yeah
i've been smoking weed my whole life
okay and i never remembered anything
i've lived in the i've hidden stuff from
myself for decades what do you mean just
molestations and things where they
didn't exist in my mind
so i'm good at trapping [ __ ] and making
it disappear and when there's a target
like something to go for you can't have
that other stuff in your mind so i'm
very good at just tunnel visioning
things which means if i tunnel vision
long enough i'll lose things
you know and if you bring up a story i
go oh yeah that's right i was i remember
that
but
sometimes i i for sure a lot uh uh i've
lost stuff but i don't think it's from
hitting my head
i talk fast man i know what's going on i
can hear stuff i move quick
as well
because you're ufc plus skateboarding
you know yeah but i'm 50 and this is
where you start to see it already you're
also jumping off a [ __ ] what was that
uh
that damn
car carrier or whatever you were trying
to land that [ __ ] brand how's that
you're how you tour your gonna do that
again though i'm gonna make it this time
i got
it'll work out way smoother than that
one i'm going to have tony hawk help
design it with me so all right we'll
have professionals look what am i going
to do
until i'm a comedian like you and i can
go like hey check out the jason ellis
tour i'm
i gotta test myself i understand that
but you don't have to be a comedian you
don't have to be uh anything you don't
have to be labeled anything you live my
life no look being real good on the
porch is not what i'm looking to do
right now maybe when it all shuts off
then yeah let's be like one of those
guys that really knows how to lamp but
right now i'm big i'm strong i can still
jump i i mean i'm funny and i want to
flex all those muscles until they go but
i think you are so i'm trying to tell
you i think you're doing a good job at
that oh yeah yeah you're doing that
thanks i got props on a skateboard
podcast yesterday and i'm still hopped
up on it like they were like yeah we see
him skating again he's ripping i'm like
no
wait the nine club is an awesome podcast
and they i thought for sure they
wouldn't even know who i am and they're
like yeah guy that had the serious show
who was a pro skateboarder good to see
him back you seem like you're having way
more fun now
well there's no money in it for me i
just do it because i love it which is
defeated
the bit that creeped in that sounded
good at the start like hey man do you
want to not have a job and skateboard
for a living [ __ ] yes i do and that's
great and you're doing all the things
that you want to do and it's popular at
the time and then you've been in it for
a decade and it's like they're doing
some new tricks now and i'm like
i don't even really like those tricks
and it's like if you don't do those
tricks in your contest ride you're going
to be you're not going to win
so you start doing stuff that you don't
want to do you start doing stuff that
you don't want to do that doesn't work
out where you get real hurt and that
becomes a job
because you're like man you know what i
could have done today is not that trick
and then i wouldn't be going to the
hospital you're talking about skating
and i'm just in my head it's comedy
because it still ends up in the hospital
dude i feel like she is still end up in
there
like just mentally
mentally damaged i'm doing stand-up that
makes sense you guys are tweeting bro i
don't know how to it's the most
nerve-wracking challenging thing i've
ever been involved in and i've had
fights with people that are way out of
my league and i could tell they weren't
playing i'm like wow you're going to get
knocked out today before i went on stage
for uh to do comedy with you at brea
that was great the most nervous my knee
would not stop shaking and i started
jumping up and down i'm backstage
jumping up and down i'm like what is
wrong with you like there's no fight
here like yeah jason ellis i'm like oh
my god this is going to be the what like
were you more nervous to do that than
everything no yes everything more
nervous than when i walked into the when
i went under the rope and popped up and
was like shane we're gonna fight and he
was not joking and his face was bright
red and i was like
oh my god he's gonna knock me out more
nervous before i had to move the curtain
to go out there the lights i usually do
the dime bar shout out to the dime bar
but it's six people you had
you had six hundred people okay
that's a nickel plus dude and usually
they're like they're the guys that are
the comedians nobody's listening to me
and even ten people yeah i know i've
done it for two people i've done it to
one and the microphone went off
i know the dying i could do in the
bathroom before i came here it would
have been the same thing
but yeah what about dropping in first
time stand-up was more scary than than
what i'm watching at those [ __ ] big
vert ramps i mean i stood at the top one
of those that's what is it how many
stories the mega man went up well the
rolling's 90 feet high but that's not
it's just a big thing to shoot you over
the gap but the quarter pipe is 30 feet
high and you do 20 foot airs on that so
you're 50 feet off the ground in the air
yeah so when you hit that ramp and you
fly over and then that gives you more
speed to hit that
how are you up there
20 feet above a 30-foot ramp
i mean that's five [ __ ] stories
it's the coolest feeling i've ever felt
does it slow down yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah if
you hear anything
no
no there's a free and if you're blowing
up and you're spinning whatever is it is
it just fluid is it slow down because
you feel it it's like an extension if
you're spinning on that ramp you've done
the spin a million times on the littler
ramps so the spin is not really that
it's it's the pop like when you take off
once you leave whatever you did it's
over
there's no wings on this so if you pop
wrong
you're [ __ ] the difference is on a
mega amp once you go past like 15 foot
above the deck
you can no longer read
where you're landing is until you get
back in the 15 foot pocket so when you
get to 20
there's a second it feels like a minute
but it's the second where you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] wait am i is is cause it could
if you're wrong you're
almost dead like one person slammed i
thought he was dead but he lived but i
didn't i don't think i could do that
slam like it looked like a normal person
it was a freaky thing that he lived jake
brown the youtube slam that is just like
his
shoes helmet come off like he explodes
it's [ __ ] incredible
so you when that when you feel that
you're like death death death and you
see and you go ah now i'm in the pocket
now get back into
being a skateboarder again and then
making it
you get used to it and then you start to
get the rhythm of it and then you can
just straight up fly like
in the end when you get used to it you
go down that thing like whoa and it's
it's a big bong like a bong the wheels
hit and it's a big it's a way louder way
harder hit because you're doing like 50
mile an hour and that's like a thing you
you do get used to and then it's just
i feel like i am flying because there's
there's no
i in when you get used to it there's no
i don't feel like i'm tensing or i did
anything to get up there it was more
like i was just
in a seat and the seat shot me into the
air like that and now i'm in this
position where i've always been in
skateboarding
my natural method error is just like
and then that feeling on the way back
down is just like the e it's the
greatest
it's
it's i think it's a little bit of a
problem because that when you get that
feeling you're like okay can i be like
uh in metallica because i don't know how
else i'm gonna
rifle this feeling of a 20-foot
backside air i mean that's what
the addiction to stand stand-up is is
that immediate reaction good or bad yeah
because it's cut through immediate this
we're recording it's going to be a
minute before it comes out yeah and then
we'll see people's comments whatever
good or bad
about this if you're lucky and you hit
your head a lot you won't even know that
they haven't remembered that yeah i'm
assuming people like stand up as you
know it's immediate yes
a little too fast sometimes like if
things aren't going good you're like ah
i don't know what else to do well i do
let's start out with some of these
[ __ ] stories over here i want to hear
burnout at a funeral okay so my dad died
and this was before i knew about any of
the other stuff so i was living in
america uh you know dad dies peddling up
a mountain
he my brother was a super cross guy so
he tried to pedal up he paddled up the
mountain said it was the hardest thing
he's ever done so my dad
new years i think
morning peddled up died on the top of
the mountain because he did a heart
attack up there yeah didn't have any
background in being
a conditioned athlete
because it's just an ego yep
so yeah he was definitely going to come
down go wasn't that hard right that was
yeah for sure he [ __ ] up on that
assessment
so
hardest thing he ever did
yeah i mean i missed him in a point
there where he's going oh man but he
kept going i'm like you idiot you know
go back down it's not for you guys
he's gonna be pissed when i make it like
oh god
um so yeah we have a funeral and then
after the funeral it's back how do you
who notifies you
do you remember
i think my
stepmom yeah my stepmom called me i
think do you go
back flew back to australia straight
away
and then uh you have a funeral you have
a funeral and you know or
it's all said and done
tough stuff for everybody obviously and
then there's a uh what is it awake is
that what do you have afterwards
so this is new for us the funeral thing
and no one's close you had never had
he's the first guy to go well my
grandmother died but i was so little
that it right i didn't you know i was
just real sad at the end so this one is
we go back to my brother's house and
he's a professional motocross rider so
he's got bikes in the garage
uh every there's a lot of moto dudes
because my brother's got like uh
supercross friends so they're all there
and so it's all the youth young guys
tattoo guys skateboard dudes everyone's
drinking and uh we're in the
fox apparel and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] i see it
[ __ ] plan b like skateboard t-shirt
dc t-shirts and [ __ ] uh yeah fox
racing [ __ ] hoodies like just the
whole
and tons of beer and i'm smoking all the
joints that you i can get and uh we did
burnouts in the garage
you just pin they put the the bike in
six and just let it [ __ ] crank in the
garage
not very big like a two-car garage so
there's like one burnout just smoking
this [ __ ] gallery three bikes in
there doing it at the same time
i wonder if this is doing anything
compared to this that is around me doing
something
weeds getting hot yeah yeah i think i'm
high i'm tired i don't know which part's
getting me fur the hardest
so uh
he opens the garage [ __ ] ship bellows
out
this guy comes
the door is closed yeah [ __ ] old
tired at least had it opened
real hard i think that was dudes doing
bong rips in there at the same time i
was like
is he doing a bomb rip that's [ __ ]
funny because you can't even breathe
so i don't even know what you're [ __ ]
breathing in at this point
no one's gonna be that bong you're not
even getting that in there something
else got there first
this is the week
yeah yeah yeah mum's not there she's
gone to bed i think so
what's how late is it
oh god probably like 10 30.
[Laughter]
neighbors know that alice one of the
alices is gone so i think they knew that
we were gonna set the streets on fire so
and then my brother takes his bike out
drunk as [ __ ] takes his bike out starts
doing
um
wheelies up and down the street for
everybody he's [ __ ] good so it's
different it's not as dangerous
and then he stops
shots [ __ ] you know everyone's
pouring alcohol over each other
and then uh
i sit down for a second and this guy
comes over [ __ ]
real serious and and introduces himself
as the burnout king
and he goes you know we i know you live
in the states chase so we haven't met
but you know you [ __ ] old man was a
top bloke and i [ __ ] i came here mate
to [ __ ] pay my respects and i hope
you don't mind but i'd like to do a
[ __ ] burnout for you for your old man
mate oh this is uh
this is a his like dedication yeah
he said it in a real mafia way where i
was like [ __ ] this is serious you know i
mean like this guy is paying homage to
the [ __ ]
turns out he brought a [ __ ] separate
tire for this burnout like
he did not [ __ ] play at all get my
death time
get my funeral tire out
it might have been a [ __ ] death tire
so
we come out to the street is it still a
no he's a car he's got a car a car he's
not a dirt bike
and on one wheel
he brought a burnout tire for it because
it's limited slip diff so it's not going
to do both
is he going to do
like a burn out with all three wheels
off the ground no no he gets one to
break free okay and as soon as it breaks
free this guy opens his door as soon as
the burnout starts he opens his door and
[ __ ] gets out looks that like
starts looking back at us like you open
the door and he's like
and it's and it's [ __ ]
my [ __ ] you know sick burn out
smoke balance my [ __ ] yeah man you're
the king and i can tell that like ow
we're impressed and he's like he you
guys don't know [ __ ] yet mate and i'm
like what is he so [ __ ] cocky about
he just keeps going keeps going this
burnout is going a [ __ ] long time
dude
now the rim is starting to glow orange
and then you see the rim glow so all of
us because we're drunk in a strand we go
towards the glow because we're like
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna say fire
[ __ ]
let's gather around this [ __ ] thing
this glowing wheel
and then also how hot that has to be to
make a rim dude
round orange circle in there so we're
all cheering it towards it and then
[ __ ] boom
tire pops and we're like whoa [ __ ]
crazy this dude is still right there
like [ __ ] nowhere near done
and it's just the rim and it's not
happening it goes boom and we're like
yeah
and then you hear him gas more
and i'm like yes you [ __ ] you know
what dude standing over it then we all
come in and then as we come in it goes
boom again and i just get hit with
[ __ ]
uh hot rubber
with pieces of metal in it because the
[ __ ] thing is melted and it's just
shouting
yeah so we all start going oh [ __ ] we're
all burning
so
some didn't get hit so they're still
rooting for him
and then he keeps going and then [ __ ]
boops fire
back of the car starts to catch on fire
and he's like sorry grab some water
you know he's like all right
and i'm [ __ ] car is on fire
the street is glowing and i mean that
we're covered in [ __ ] burning hot
rocks coming out little metal spikes
that were like in me and i was like what
is that like that's was that in me
like holy [ __ ] thank god i'm so wasted
right now that i can't feel the burning
rubber and steer my face
[Laughter]
thank god only one person died you know
what's crazy is if there was a murderer
in your neighborhood yeah i know you
didn't be murdered as [ __ ] that's how he
died and that's how that's how we died
because of stup we all wanted to do it
always went like that
but that guy still he listens to the
show now because the podcast yeah what's
what's his name
can you say don't say what's up burnout
yeah yeah just do that yeah but yeah he
uh he buys wolf knife [ __ ] does he yeah
i've seen him post stuff he tags me and
stuff so we had we had a small drag
strip in maryland at uh it's called 75
and 80 because it was right at 75 and
80. okay and you could take your
personal car there whatever it was just
a quarter mile and these guys would come
and they would do drag race nights some
funny car night whatever but a lot of
local dudes souping up their novas and
[ __ ] you know what i mean yep i get that
and um they'll pull up and they would
have these rednecks that would stand
shirtless six seven of them behind it
and when these guys would like their
tires up to warm them up before they
pull up for the christmas tree they
would stand there like that and to
intentionally take the [ __ ] and
they'd be like yeah i've never forgotten
it just eating that [ __ ] rubber no
it's not it's not it's moto man it's not
lighting up till it's [ __ ] glowing
yeah but yeah i've never seen i've seen
a lot of burnouts i've never seen a guy
do a burnout like that still to this day
oh it was the greatest burnout i've ever
seen all right let me see this one let
me hear about uh prostitutes in
amsterdam
oh i thought we were gonna not do
prostitutes i thought you just like i
don't know just thought we've done dick
[ __ ] stuff like here jason [ __ ] whoo
i saw one time in amsterdam uh a friend
of mine got into a disagreement with
some uh working girls and there was a
double-ended dildo involved
and when i not in anybody yeah like they
had it as a weapon and they were chasing
him yeah it was like because amsterdam
has little corridors and stuff and he
came flying by me and i was like whoa i
wonder what his deal is and then two
chicks come running after one had a
double-ended dildo chasing him i was
like that's pretty cool
yeah
i wouldn't mind running after that to
see where that was
i don't need to be walking toward
glowing tires or something like we're
running after these two [ __ ] with the
double dildo that seems safe a bit right
yeah but yeah i'll leave the amsterdam
thing alone i think what else what other
questions you have you have uh fighting
with dad in the alley oh yeah so i got
in a one time i got into a fight my dad
was a fighter when he was a young guy
like street fighter guy got into a lot
of fights and
real bad temper what did he do for a
living he worked in an electronics store
what like electronics mate
what elastronics
for real [ __ ] yeah so he owned his own
business his
mother and father owned it okay and then
he
took over when the my his gran his
mother died
and then my grandfather kind of went we
like he's at one point when he worked
there he was kind of fried and
gone he would tell stories about how
cheap tomatoes are compared to melbourne
to queensland
and then he would fart loudly
and act like he didn't fart and walk off
like you could be he'd be like how's
your day address and i'd be like that's
pretty and i'm in the middle of telling
him how my day is and he just walks off
he farted at me and walked off i'm like
is he
but he didn't mean it he's just like
kind of gone he ended up moving to
queensland and becoming a um
a trans woman your grandfather yeah my
dad was real bummed about that i
remember coming back from america once
he picked me up from the airport and
he's like [ __ ] jock
you're gonna believe this i'm like what
because he called him chuck they were
not cool with each other they definitely
he my dad did not like his dad
and he goes [ __ ]
guys just a [ __ ] woman i mean what do
you mean he's like [ __ ] he's a woman
thinks he's a [ __ ] woman driving
around like a [ __ ] idiot like a woman
i'm like well he's still your dad you
know what i mean like i wasn't i didn't
know the doctor's mom now but still
and he's your grandma now but either way
let's love the [ __ ]
i never realized i had a grandma again
that's [ __ ] up
i loved my grandma
my granddad yeah but when he became a
grandmother well how long is a
grandmother well i got i was really i
know we're living but i wouldn't know i
couldn't hang with him because my dad
was so mad oh you weren't even allowed
to be around i didn't i was embarra one
time i saw him on the street i was in i
was in queensland skateboard contest and
i was at a light and i knew the car
because my dad had one of those little
mini cars that he bought and he bought
it for his dad so i drove it a few times
before it went up to queensland so i
knew the car and it was back when not a
lot of people had this real little car
and i was like oh wow that's [ __ ]
grandma's car or granddad's car
and i go oh [ __ ] it's him with a wig on
and i'm like [ __ ]
so i just didn't look and then the car
drove off because i didn't want to
engage him i thought it would be
embarrassing on for him and me but a
skateboard buddy who lived in queensland
was his neighbor
and one time on the vern ramp he just
said to me hey man did your granddad
live in queensland i was like yeah hey
wise like yeah my grandma does that
wasn't a good grandma it was a it was he
didn't have a lot of money to be like a
convincing grandma yeah he was an old
dude dressed as a lady i see so but he
had new gay friends and i think he was
going out a little bit and like sucking
some dicks before he died so i'm happy
you know i think he had a little gay
scene for a minute and probably got a
couple of blowies but also you don't
have one
to do that oh he's eight he was 87 or
something do you think that if you want
to get laid at 87 you're better shot at
it as a woman than a 87 year old woman
and an 87 year old man
if you're
thinking if you're a gay guy and you're
87 you can still get sucked off i i'm
sure you can if you're 87 and you're a
straight guy
you're not getting sucked off you could
pay for it oh yeah right well you're
probably gonna pay a gay guy to do it
not i'm just kidding one time i went to
a uh man
a gay bath house uh-huh and there was
guys in there that were
that age and they get a little candle
and they got their bed and they're all
set up they're like come on in you know
what i mean i'm like wow ready to go
it's like that
and people are you know people are doing
them did i ever tell you about the
accidental um
gay
uh bath house i went to massage massage
parlor i went to no i'll share this with
you because you'll appreciate this
so
i always want like i don't get
demonetized just so you know what's this
is long
bro
this was the monetize before it was up
um oh man listen if you are out there
renting or you're looking to buy a home
so many of us can't afford it but i'm
telling you there is a way to do it
that's why i highly recommend checking
out the how to buy a home podcast this
is an incredible resource for anyone who
is interested in buying a home whether
that's in the next month the next year
or in five years who knows 2022 could be
the year you finally own your own place
host david cedoni has been helping
first-time home buyers like us for years
in his how to buy a home podcast the
answer is questions like when is the
best time to start how do i even start
do i really need to put 20 down and the
answer is no most people only put down
3.5 percent and david will tell you how
is a mortgage going to be more than your
current monthly rent probably not you
can even reach out directly to david for
one-on-one advice he's already connected
several honeydew listeners who are all
first-time home buyers with great local
realtors all over the u.s to make sure
they have someone in their corner listen
to the how to buy a home podcast today
for your step-by-step guide for buying
your first home find how to buy a home
wherever you listen to podcasts whether
it's saving more and spending less
getting organized or losing weight
there's a lot of worthwhile goals to set
for yourself this year at the top of my
list you know i'm trying to learn a new
language with babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions i'm working on my
espanol and it's going muy bien y'all
not only is learning a new language a
fun and engaging new hobby you can use
it while you're traveling the whole
babel process is addictively fun it's
fast and it's easy babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons for the real
world to use okay so when you go on i go
on i do my lessons right they speak it
for you you go on you speak back you
actually speak it you have to hit your
accents and everything and trust me
sometimes with this accent i have to say
it two three times but i know what i'm
saying you're doing your tests your
readings everything and then they do
again in little mini bite size you're
always getting reinforced it's fantastic
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with babel in addition to lessons
you can access podcasts games video
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
start your new language learning journey
today with babel right now when you
purchase a three-month babel
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code honeydew
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babel language for life
now let's get back to the do i like to
like i don't get enough massages i don't
i don't take care of my body that way
enough i know i don't you know so
every now and then i would get like a
burke williams gift certificate or
something i love that [ __ ] i'm telling
the ladies i work with at these writing
gigs producing gigs and stuff like oh
you know i like that spot and they're
all telling me about the korean spas out
here how fantastic they are
and they're like what does it suck you
off though it's so it's they're like
it's the same thing as burke williams
but like half the price and blah blah
blah i'm like okay
so i listen to the ladies
and i
you'll love this this is all i'll never
forget this is mother's day a few years
ago
my daughter's mom has her for mother's
day i drop her off
like happy mother's day enjoy your day
and then i'm like you know what ryan
i know it's mother's day but [ __ ] it go
do something nice for yourself when you
have her your mom and dad go [ __ ] do
something nice and celebrate yourself i
was like that's what i'm gonna do so
i get this info from this chick i'm
working with to go to this little korean
spa
uh down olympic
a little you know massage day spa
whatever
i walk in and these ladies barely speak
english and um but i'm trying to ask
about
services and [ __ ]
and she's like she
literally says you'll figure it out okay
i walk through this little bamboo
curtain and i make a right-hand turn
and it might as well been a thousand
dicks just pop papa popped me in the
face like that was the equivalent of
what was going on in there when i walked
in i was like
oh man
yeah it was i was it was on on all right
and i was like that might have been the
one i used to go to
it's always on in there
so i always wondered what it'd be like
to be a straight guy yeah and not
knowing it
yes very soon now
let me tell you i got a story i'll tell
you it's because i was that guy i walk
in and i'm like
all right you know it's all i mean it's
all gay dudes and i go and they say all
right your massage is going to be at
this time but you've got a little time
to kill um at certain time somehow i'll
flag you take you i'm like okay steam
room did you
well i'll get there
so
i go around the corner and i go to i
want to get in the pool you know dip in
the pool and i walk up
and i'm telling this dude this dude's
[ __ ] you know he's just chilling on
the side like this and his dick
is hanging over that [ __ ] edge of the
pool and it's it's touching the water
yeah and i'm just like i can't not look
i'm just like jesus he wants you to
yeah of course he's on display
everyone's talking to him sounds like an
impressive dick it's an impressive day
even more of a reason to drop that thing
it's an impressive dick you know it's
just hanging there i'm like oh whatever
you're a shower
yeah okay that's probably what it is so
anyway
so i get in whatever and i'm telling you
there's there's
[ __ ] in the water oh
oh that's not the one i go to so then
this i don't know if it's [ __ ] [ __ ] but
it's not clean and then this guy calls
me and it's my massage right
and i'm like are you taking me to he's
like over here i was like who's giving
me this massage i think he's taking me
to a lady
oh he's like i'm giving you this massage
this is an old ass dude i'm like what
the [ __ ] what's wrong with that
wait you don't get dude massages no i i
i've only had one before um when i
worked at a hotel we would have a
masseuse come in all the time and we
would get a free massage from that
person so that we could recommend them
to
uh
and this one dude came in um and he was
olympic i think he's worked with nadia
the famous olympic uh
gymnast oh okay i think she was uh
russian i believe and um this dude knew
the body you know what i'm saying he was
just yeah it wasn't just uh someone
rubbing right this guy was scientific
and that's probably the sports massage
that's what i'm saying i've ever had
from that dude yeah no doubt and i would
recommend him that's what i do let's get
massages from yeah sportsmanship this
guy nothing screams sports masseuse
about this right now it's korean spa
known for uh what i call i'm like
when are you going to jerk me off
because this massage is that bad that it
obviously comes with a hand job
but anyway so the guy's like i'm your
guy not going to a private room we're
going to a room there's eight [ __ ]
tables in this room
all wide open yeah
so
he's like all right go over there and
shower first i go over and shower and
there's
chairs recliners so you can sit and just
watch dude shower you know
so now i go over and i'm like don't
leave
you're you're comfortable enough i'm
having this conversation don't be a
[ __ ]
it's just [ __ ]
you know
gay guys whatever not a big deal
so i go lay down for the massage
this dude
is aggressively scrubbing you know he's
going oh
damn thing okay yeah get the body scrub
going home i hate that they get all this
what is it that
dead skin off or whatever but it hurts
but also i'm i i'm not
ocd to the point but i'm clean i like my
place clean
he's scrubbing us and i'm watching them
over here and they're just bucketing
just taking water buckets
all over the floor nobody's coming in
here cleaning this [ __ ] up his [ __ ]
dead ass skin all over the floor of this
[ __ ] place i'm like oh
and then i start having a real
conversation with myself like i have
i think one
maybe two times i've gotten
hard from a massage i just never have
i've either fallen asleep or whatever
like the person one time was this old
ass asian lady and she took uh what she
did was she i was laying on my back and
the sheet was across me and she just
kept grabbing the sheet on the sides and
pulling it so it pressed down on my dick
like this
she knew what she was doing
it worked
it did i was like she made my thing
did she say anything nothing
professional and then i had another lady
that purposely would do like she would
like crack like do massage like a
chiropractic crack or whatever and she'd
put my arm in her crotch and [ __ ] like
that and she'd hand constantly going
over me and [ __ ] but not but a legit
place like there's kids in the lobby and
[ __ ] and i was like
i know what you're doing you're getting
that tip girl don't worry about it
but still that's it
and all of them
so i'm worried i genuinely am having a
conversation like what if i get an
erection like what is that man why would
you go there why'd you think he might
get a boner did that make you get a
boner no okay good cause i'm gonna tell
you what happened he's like okay lay on
your lay face down here and i lay face
down and this motherfucker's feet i see
him in these flip-flops oh dad my
his toes match the job he did okay you
know scrub it like the [ __ ] oh it was
disgusting yeah and i'm laughing i'm
laughing he's scrubbing i am laughing so
hard this motherfucker's rolling me over
and i know it's what i'm saying here is
he's just he's going up the crack of my
ass he's kicking
in my groin like he is moving my dick
and balls to the side literally like
it's his job you know what i think and
i'm thinking to myself
this dude
is either the most miserable
[ __ ]
and at what point did he make a wrong
turn that landed him here or
he is right where he [ __ ] wants to be
and he loves his [ __ ] job i
couldn't decide but he kept bucking my
[ __ ] old skin off on the floor i took
a shower okay i still don't have my
shoulders all the way down you know what
i mean i don't have them all the way
down
so now i go into the steam room
and i [ __ ] that cloud parts it was
like the burnout king when i went in
not the same thing you saw though
you know what i'm good guys i'm good
uh so i leave okay at this point i'm a
good hour or whatever in now hour and a
half i leave and i'm just like man
that was not relaxing yeah i went to
relax
pat yourself on the back ryan our little
personal moment you were in there naked
with everybody else you were comfortable
you were fine whatever
no biggie let's go to burke williams and
get the [ __ ] massage you want you
listen to all these chicks at work
i get there and they say well today's
mother's day so we're only open for
women i go what kind of [ __ ] come on man
i go are you [ __ ] kidding me i go can
i ask you a question are you only open
for men on father's day no i go well
then why are you only open for women on
mother's day
and i didn't and i didn't i promise you
i did not get another massage it took
like another year it took a year for me
to finally go get that massage i really
wanted to [ __ ] get
well i'm sorry you went to the wrong
place to get jerked off
back
yeah please that sounds terrible i've
accidentally had one of those things
where they wash you with that scrub
thing and it's a bummer i was like oh
wait i didn't i wanted to get a massage
whatever the [ __ ] this is not what i
wanted it was a like a body scrub or
something i was like no no no no i don't
want that yeah anyway give me uh
fighting with dad in the alley sorry oh
yeah so
he's an aggressive kind of guy and we
worked together at tech's
er sorry at allistonix it was tec as he
changed who's your boss yeah how old are
you at this time
17 probably uh and my friend met me
to
catch a train with me or something or
one we're gonna go somewhere or
something so he met me after work and
there's an alleyway beside the shop
and a back way out so
i'm leaving it's after work
uh
my dad leaves at the same time and i
remember going hey can i get it right he
was like [ __ ] right and he walked off to
go get his car i was like [ __ ]
and then he gets he had a range rover at
the time he gets to he gets
to the car and a guy driving through the
alleyway
super fast
goes past the car when dad opens the
door and almost hits the door
and dad's like you [ __ ] idiot and
then the guy pulls
immediately hits the brakes and winds
the window down and puts his arm down
and hand out and points to the ground
like come here and say it yeah so
i'm in the middle so this happens where
i see dad say that and then i look to
the other side and see that guy do that
and i'm like that looks like a big arm
too
look a long arm
so my dad starts walking towards him
he's already ready to fight and he's i
could tell like he's going to the point
where i go dad don't and he just pushed
me out of the way walked towards the guy
guy gets out of the car he's like six
foot five i'm like [ __ ] hell man like
i don't want to i don't really a part of
this i'm scared for him you know it
seems like a bad matchup as soon as he
gets within swinging distance starts
throwing hooks you know street fighting
uh technique just [ __ ] hook hook hook
dude takes a shot steps back on the wall
spins that around front teeps him so he
can kick box he [ __ ]
shoots it's it's where you you shoot you
lift your front foot up and you shoot it
into their stomach like a stabbing it's
not a kick it's more of a push
and pushed him into the wall and and
post it up and i was like i just saw
that and freaked out and
ran at the guy
and just cuz he was so tall let me stop
you there for a second because i have a
question
this is your dad who's put you through
hell there's no point in you or you're
like let him [ __ ] take this [ __ ]
open and stink instinctively you're
going to defend him i love my dad at
that point i didn't know that i was
involved in any of that other stuff and
i also didn't realize that any of the
many things that i was engaging with
through him were really bad at this
point i was like my dad is the coolest
he will punch you in the face if you
look at him the wrong way and he will
[ __ ] all your women and he'll give me
one
he's the man you give me one oh he's the
man
so
i didn't know i was trained to be a
piece of [ __ ] dude okay so
yeah i remember as soon as that he
looked like he was in trouble and he
hadn't even got hit yet it just looked
like maybe this was going to be a fair
fight and i didn't want to watch my dad
get beat up
so i
jumped i ran and jumped and got him in a
headlock but i remember i had to jump up
high to get him in a headlock so then i
got him in the headlock i bring his head
down i start uppercutting him in the
face and i'm crying man like i'm not
cool about it like i'm i'm like
hysterical while i'm punching him in the
face how old's this guy you think
25 30.
and then i put his head because he left
the door open and i started punching him
towards the car and i put his head in
the [ __ ] door and started slamming
his head in the [ __ ] door yeah and
then my dad get out of the way jayla and
and the guy goes all right all right all
right and i'm like you're [ __ ] done
you're not cool i'm like you [ __ ]
dirty [ __ ] done like and he's like
yeah all right all right i'm like just
leave him alone like just stop everyone
stop
and and the guy gets in the car and
drives off and i walk next to my dad
like two or three steps and he goes you
took your [ __ ] time
thank you
he's joking
he's not serious but he's joking in
[ __ ] two seconds i've got tears still
coming down my face and i'm like what
are you
it's not funny this is not funny man
like [ __ ] freaking out and then he
[ __ ] gets in the car and didn't drive
and said he was like see
he's [ __ ] lit at me
and my friend was like
what the [ __ ] did i just sing
you two are [ __ ] insane
i remember just talking to him on the
train the whole way to the escape room
be like yeah i don't know what that was
terrifying man terrifying moment um
tell me this one about the boar oh okay
so this is
a little bit this is cool this is fun so
i i i hunt when i was a kid i grew up
hunting
in you know only
uh rabbits and
when i was younger real young i shot a
kangaroo and stuff you know
it was different
do people eat kangaroo yeah well my
friends is it like deer is it yeah it's
all it looks like
yeah so my dad's friends totally did
that and one of my dad's friends would
like use their he would make necklaces
because he was like a a pretend native
american australian so he he would stay
in a teepee when he camped he made his
own tp and he had like [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] on oh and i'm like you're [ __ ]
you're from [ __ ] melbourne what but
he lived for it smoke weed all day and
[ __ ] tp all that [ __ ] so he would
make necklaces out of it and they would
kill you know shoot goannas and you know
they shot like a seven foot go one
second what's that it's a really big
lizard that it's almo it's like a looks
like a dinosaur kind of yeah i think i
know like those uh what are they those
monitors or whatever it looks like that
okay i know what you're talking about
yeah they are so the point where across
the road when we were driving down the
road look at the [ __ ] size of that
pull up gun's out this thing goes up a
tree dad shoots it out of the tree
one shot in the head blew the side of
its head off go get it jay
and i grab the tail and it turns around
goes
with another face scared the [ __ ] oh my
god yeah and they're like
i will make [ __ ] nickels out of that
no worries and i'm like okay
that'd be my last day hunting ever right
that was always that [ __ ] with me did
the boar hunting before this story the
we go boar hunting and i don't know that
much about it my dad's now excited about
boar hunting different guns
bigger guns but are you really bore
hunting are you doing that [ __ ] they
doing like [ __ ] louisiana or they
take you out in a truck where they feed
a trough of them and you just go wipe
them out dude we're not this is this is
this is hunting it it's most dangerous
you're giving them a huge chance that's
how we do it okay so at one point he big
fire
and i don't know why but apparently
these boys decided to attack our fire in
the middle of the night and i had
20 damn
get out the tree i'm like get up the
tree what why how do you know
and my one of my friends uh one of my
dad's friends was a czechoslovakian guy
that escaped from czech prison he had
like uh he said he swam over uh a lake
where they had like uh barbed wire on
the they had to crawl through barbed
wire to get out of the river or whatever
and he had a tattoo that he got uh
there's a [ __ ] tattoo so he put acid and
sandpaper and rubbed he said tattoo hurt
too much so it's half done it's like
this half rubbed out tattoo that he got
in prison and he i'll never forget this
we were working on a house together my
friend
him
and myself working on her house and uh
he talked about jail for a second i was
like so how was that jeff and he goes
that's not so bad
i didn't get i mean i only had to suck a
dick a few times no no [ __ ] the ass
and i remember my friend and i were so
young
that
he said it from behind and so he wasn't
in front of me but when he said it i
went
to my friend and he looked at me like
should we even be here if he's saying
that
it was so terrifying that he thought
sucking a dick was not that bad
because he didn't get [ __ ] in the eyes
i'm like that doesn't seem good still
so jeff is not the name i thought was
going to be with this guy he's a generic
barbarian rapper
rapids are called rapids because he
can't he still had a strong accent
and uh so he's dead get the you get the
tractor seat welded on the on the bull
bar so you got the little seat belt and
you're on there with the spotlights and
wherever they go you [ __ ] shoot them
so uh
that day
when they stampeded the fire
i'm in the tree with jeff
i've got my shotgun my dad cut off the
uh the handle and the nozzle so that i
could aim it because i was too young to
keep the barrel pointed at [ __ ] it was
too heavy
so i had my own little pump action
shotgun shotgun
jeff drops out of the tree and starts
gunning them no so i jump out of the
trees rambo down and you went with them
yeah and i started gunning them so i
don't know where i'm aiming you know i
mean i'm just like
and then i hit one
and ree r
it's [ __ ] screaming pig dog goes
running over there to get him and these
dogs i don't know what they are because
we don't have
pit bulls we have are they like
ridgebacks american bulldogs i don't
know what it is but they're big
short-haired [ __ ] with that no you
know he is cut off one of those [ __ ]
monsters and i'll never forget it he had
a huge
uh uh collar big thick one all studded
big black thick one and when he went in
to get the pig the tusk went underneath
the collar and the pig went like that
[ __ ] ragged all that dog like [ __ ]
20 feet snapped the collar off damn
those things are no joke but that
thing's gotta stand you're gonna you
jump down on the ground level started
running at me you weren't scared [ __ ]
[ __ ] terrifying he's on the ground
because they're doing it if i don't do
it i'm a [ __ ]
you gotta do
what the [ __ ] is that i'm like i dropped
out of the tree yeah all right let's go
so i killed that guy
shooting him in the face coming at me
and then uh they're like all right you
know you're gonna skin it and they teach
me how to skin it so they put they put
his legs up on a
hooked up on a tree so he's dangling
upside down give me the meat cleaver and
they're all gathered around because you
know jay is like 11 12
and they're like you know this would be
fun watch jay he's like you know you're
chop down into the groin chop all the
way down pull all these guts out and
then chop off his head so you know i'm
chopping into this thing and i can tell
they're like oh good well g [ __ ] chop
into the [ __ ] thing and then i'm
chopping the neck and here i'm whipping
it in there like [ __ ] get him jake
get him jay get his [ __ ] head off you
know i'm like hey mate come on
kill this [ __ ] it's already dead i
don't know what's going on so i get the
head off
i'm gonna get the head off i pick it up
everyone's going hey
he's got the [ __ ] head you know
because it was just
right there and it was like a little
pocket where it would fit on there a
little bit because my head was small so
and then they're like get the [ __ ]
camera that's hilarious jake
there's a photo of it somewhere [ __ ]
guy that done once some thousand island
dressing splashing him in a food fight
you wore a boar's [ __ ] hat well it's
you're a different frame of mind
when you're doing that you're you're a
killer there's blood not gushing all
over yourself
[ __ ] it it's warm as [ __ ] stinks
stinks like [ __ ] [ __ ] and innards
because that's what i had to clean the
poop out of his butthole oh because you
got to get the meat clean and then uh
jeff bless his heart
you know he teaches me all that he's
like this is how you [ __ ] cut the
meat and he's showing me how to cut off
pieces he's like uh kidneys is good and
my dad going to [ __ ] eat the kidneys
that's disgusting and just like nice
good with a bit of salt good
and then uh we barbecued the kidneys and
he put garlic salt and salt on there and
me and him him and i shared how was it
it was good was it yeah
yeah i was surprised is bore very
similar to just pig is it very much kind
of tell you what it tasted like like we
were just
is that the only time you've ever had it
no i
so i ate pig a apologize but it was just
barbecued over the [ __ ] fire it was
burnt meat man like we're talking dudes
jeff had garlic salt and that's about as
far as i saw anybody with like a spice
everyone else is just you cook it and
then you eat it then you man everyone
else is [ __ ] j here's the thing i
like about jeff too is he he knew he was
gonna eat that [ __ ] thing he wasn't
even scared when he dropped on the
ground because he brought garlic you
don't bring garlic salt if you think
you're gonna lose no no he's abs he may
he ate a lot of weird stuff he would
always
compare showing off
and also part ridiculously tough he this
is the craziest one my brother was
probably
five or six
and he's on the back
of a four-wheeler
and i'm on the back of my dad's
four-wheeler and we're burning around
like [ __ ] maniacs going fast as hell
uh i don't even think we had helmets on
and there was this big hill that like
came to look like impossible to get up
so dad's like let's [ __ ] try and go
up it
to the point where the wheel starts
spinning and [ __ ] turn around
jeff not as good a rider as my father
straight up this uh this hill and i'm
i'm right near it so i watch it
and then it tips
it tips lee falls on the ground
and jeff sees the bike coming at him and
goes over lee in a push-up and the
four-wheeler went
over him and i remember like he made
like a table all over them
safely
saved my son my brother my brother was
like like it didn't hit it i remember
thinking and it hit him so hard and i
remember him looking at my dad god oh
you're all right your kids are right and
i'm like you guys are so [ __ ] tough
like
you look like you got really hurt
whenever they broke bones they'd always
not go to the hospital like they'd hang
out drink a few beers help put the bikes
back on the trailer [ __ ] that people did
don't do anymore you know your arms
shattered [ __ ] you be right i'm like
your face is [ __ ] grey
you're dying yeah [ __ ] you'll be
right [ __ ] help me wash the bikes
weird i'm like help you wash the bikes
go to hospital oh
in a minute
um i want to hear this one about you
made out i don't want to say it i don't
want to give it up the make out
okay so this is my
this is the beginning of uh old people
old women having sex with my underaged
ass
so it wasn't really
but i've been
worse molestations when i was younger so
when somebody's making out with me that
i think is kind of hot then it's not
molestation i'm like a young boy i would
have done it anyway so it's not the only
thing that scared me with all that stuff
is i felt like i treated women in a bad
way for a long time because i just
figured everybody just wanted to get
[ __ ]
these two
so
uh new year's dad got a houseboat my
dad's best friend and his wife that at
one point had changed my diapers that i
was told
uh she's on the houseboat she was like
super fit red-headed chick how old
35 at the time probably how old are you
16.
so
um new year's at a pub off the side of
the river the murray river so it's just
a little pub bunch of you know aussie
dudes and girls at a real [ __ ] pub
celebrating new year's
uh you know the
two three or four countdown and then
[ __ ] happy new year and i look over
my dad
makes out with this the chick the the
guy's wife yeah and i'm like what the
[ __ ] and i go to where's the guy i go to
look where he is he's making out with my
stepmom
and i'm like
whoa new year's is crazy
and then i get a tap on the shoulder and
i turn around and it's her and she just
flat out when your dad's making out with
yeah she starts making out with me
father
dude that happened a couple of times at
one point but i mean that's sec that's
like just a moment ago her your dad's
tongue's in her mouth yeah at the time i
never thought of that because i had not
been
there i wasn't aware of the scar yet
dude i was i was like [ __ ] yeah we both
made out with her
no concept of that being a bad thing or
a weird thing just gross yes yeah nasty
not even close to thinking it just like
yeah so that and i remember
when i've got a my face off her face my
only concern was my stepmom
because my stepmom was the only grounded
person in my life my mom i love her mum
but man was anal she was anal retentive
you know if you do that you can do this
and watch out [ __ ] you know safety
first man [ __ ] spare me like it was
always she's the worst
it was [ __ ] common sense she was
trying to instill some common sense into
our [ __ ] maniac brains and my dad
would just ruin it every time oh [ __ ]
enough slow down steve [ __ ] off man go
fast remember jay when you go we always
go faster you know like what i don't
know what he was trying to teach him but
it wasn't good
so
that was
the first where i'm like what is that
and then later on she she did end up
sleeping with me and so did her two
sisters what yeah and one of them was
going out with dad
so when i
so i'm under eight were you underage at
the time they slept with you too yeah
i turned 17
and then i was because it went on for a
couple years with one of them it went on
for like four or five years until my
stepmom
found out and then made me tell her to
call the house while she was in the
other room on the other house phone
listening because i always kept trying
to tell her it's not my [ __ ] fault
she wants to sleep with me she loves me
and she's like shut up jason that's
ridiculous like it's your fault and then
she was on the phone talking about
how much she cares for me and then mine
goes
hello you know so-and-so that's how she
busted yeah get off the phone jason
off the phone i don't know what they
discussed but they were no longer
friends ever again i think they are cool
now but they don't associate how did it
happen the first time how does it happen
so the first time it's happened my
parents
let a child know in this situation
especially if it's a kid a boy that was
like i'm in
you're right so it was at my parents
house and there was a big party
and at one point people had gone or
fallen asleep and i was in the living
room and this the one that we're talking
about's sister
starts to get tired and she puts her
head on my lap
and then she starts to like nuzzle my
dick
and then she like starts to like grab it
and i get up because i'm like what
if my dad comes in i'm [ __ ] dead like
you can't i'm that's all i was thinking
right you're dead if you get caught so i
get up and i'm like what the [ __ ] was
that going to the bathroom
the door opens when i'm in the bathroom
and it's the other one damn and she goes
come at me and i'm like what where into
spare room and then it's on probably
lasted like three seconds i can't
believe the shit's even happening and
then i go back into my bedroom go to bed
and then the next day dad goes
would you give it to last night i was
like uh you know nothing nothing he's
like [ __ ] i'm like what are you
talking about it's like i went into a
bedroom last night you weren't there
you're in carmel's
you're in that person's room sorry you
wanna mark that i i don't think she you
you don't know her last name but you
know what you [ __ ]
creep her name's carmel
so
she
you know you guys you weren't in there
and i was like okay so yeah
and it wasn't i wasn't in trouble it was
more like what's that like and i was
like ah
that's good i guess you know like and
then
the youngest sister i go back to america
come back again i'm at a [ __ ]
nightclub chases hard and fast they used
to sponsor me and give me drink cards
every wednesday loved my life right
there
um i get a the pa system jason ellis
report to the desk it's an emergency i'm
like whoa what's wrong
hello
jace it's jenny like uh want to come get
you come party with us i'm like karma
wants you and i'm like oh okay
come get me
comes gets me in a taxi and then taxi on
the way home she goes let's just stop at
the beach for a second i'm like yeah
okay
tuck her on the beach put a bunch of
sand in her vagina
then she gets me back in the taxi and
gives me to
carmel to
jam three sisters and then i tell my dad
at work the next day you're not going to
believe who [ __ ] burned me
and he goes who and i say jenny and he
goes you're [ __ ] joking me and i'm
like why why why is that he's like i'm
going to dinner with her tonight and i'm
like
you mean dinner like you're gonna [ __ ]
her you know because i this is when i
was
it was starting to register that it
wasn't right because i love my brothers
and that's my brother's mum and as much
as the beef that i had with her
you're if lee found out he'd be
devastated
and now i'm carrying that like i have to
not tell anybody or my brothers
so there was a little that was like the
initial part of me feeling like
this isn't right you know but that was
it wasn't it was for a brief moment to
be honest off i went on my
tangents again i was involved in a
couple of times where he picked me up
jay come to the beach i'm in my
speedboat got a outboard that can do uh
98 mile an hour got a new pa a new thing
that makes it do a hundred
and then i'm driving with him this girl
and this other girl
i'm driving it going as fast as i can
and they and she taps me jace look out
for your dad and i turn around and he's
sitting on the outboard with the beer in
his hand i'm doing like 70 mile an hour
dude you come off your [ __ ] kidneys
are coming at your ass
you go eat them with some [ __ ] garlic
i um
i never realized being a twin that i was
a bucket list for someone until later
yeah in college i was like
my brother and i were talking like you
[ __ ] her and he's like yeah i'm like
god damn it then there were a couple
other ones and i was like
oh they're f no no we didn't [ __ ] them
they're [ __ ] us yeah separately but
it's like i [ __ ] these two twins as
long as it's not at the same time you're
in the clear yeah i don't care about
that i would never do that with my
brother i won't see that right
we're different like that but i'm saying
yeah we are but i'm saying i didn't
realize that i was a check you know what
i mean yeah
you think girls never think about being
a twin i never think about it
you think women would have more class
they don't not the everybody's human
and sometimes even
women with their sophisticated minds go
twin my [ __ ] both of them what's that
like
good for them
i should ask them it was better that's
what i would have done
first i wanted at that time i didn't
know but i will if i find out i'm gonna
all right let's do this last one dad ran
from the cops
okay so this is cool so my dad super
into racing and he got a d there's this
guy named peter brock he died but he's a
race car driver in australia that was
like a legend like uh what is your
nascar like uh you know that
dale earnhardt he's like that up for us
like at one point he was winning the
race so well that he wound down the
window and he had his arm out the window
and everybody in australia loved him for
we thought he was the best and then he
had a signature car
uh holden is like al ford i think
holden's gone now in australia but at
one point it was the biggest car company
in australia and they had the holden
peter brock special and that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] tricked like super [ __ ]
like now illegal supercharged like fast
as [ __ ]
so he gets a peter brock special ute
and so he's got like the business paying
for it or whatever so i think it might
have even had like
like elastronics logos on it like it was
not an incognito car
and
him and his friend drunk strip club
taking off burn around cops start
chasing them
they put on a chase
dad escapes from them to the point where
he [ __ ] pulls up to make a joke
with his friend in the passenger seat
that i'll wait for him
so the friend's like you're [ __ ]
joking me steve he's like i'll be
[ __ ] funny we'll wait for him and
then he waited for him yeah and then
took off again
that's upset smoke in a bed right into
the into the city and then he said he
was in the city going down the road and
there was cops on either side
on the side streets trying to follow him
so then you like span around pull in
some side street [ __ ] there's a house
parks in the driveway throws the keys in
the bushes and just walks off with his
friend
he comes back goes to strip club comes
back
cops everywhere everyone's around this
car and he walks by and one of the cops
goes this is your car
and my dad goes
nah where why are you asking me that
he's like because you're walking over
here staring at it he's like yeah
no idea who that is he's like well if it
is your car you can come pick the keys
up in the morning
i don't know how that works
in australia but you cops
you can be kind of drunk sometimes and
they'll be like you just piss off you
know and you're like oh thanks mate a
lot
less into [ __ ] you over i think it's
changed a little bit now but at one
point it just seemed to be especially
for reckless driving and being a drunk
because everybody in australia was
driving reckless and drunk so it was
tough to like point out someone
so he ends up going to the
yeah doesn't go home goes to strip club
because strip club in australia can stay
out all night
goes back there in the morning like six
in the morning and they give him the
[ __ ] keys ah hey i remember him
telling he's like [ __ ]
flat spot of my [ __ ] tires locking it
up trying to [ __ ] wait for the cops
[ __ ]
i'm like you flat spotted your tires
you ain't no burnout king i'll tell you
no no
if only there was truth in dying and
seeing people looking down then he would
have been very proud of that that
burnout and for all of us being into
being set fire while it's happening yeah
it's a hell of a way a hell of a week
yeah now the way it is it was unmatched
it was like the next one my brother died
and was like don't do a burnout
burdecking it's not going to be mad
you're not going to match it
we'll just leave that last one again
dude thank you so much for coming on
anytime good to get back on my show i
feel like
you're too [ __ ] busy tour boy i can't
get you you'll get me all right um
please again promote everything uh
yeah the hawk vs wolf
it's available everywhere and it's
awesome i got a youtube channel as well
as well it's separate and i'm copying i
saw a hundred thousand i got a hundred
thousand [ __ ] so i didn't even know
that so thank you everybody that did
that without me even knowing
i really appreciate that i put my stand
up on there with
with you so that's the highlight of my
[ __ ] videos for the year
uh i did alice made the other day so
that's available free on youtube if
anyone wants to see people that can't
fight punch each other in the face
totally free and available whenever you
want
uh wolf knives with knife store.com
and uh the jason alice show
that's my baby has been for 15 16 years
so
we're still going strong i love it
thank you man and uh as always ryan
sickler and all social media ryan
sickler.com we will talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you